ce week-end un ramassage des algues a eu
lieu dans le bourg de sainte marie mais
c'est ici au bord d'une autre plage à la
riche et que les sargasses ont été
déversés stockage de courtes robes
longues durées personne ne sait mais ce
n'est pas du goût de ces samaritain
d'autant que nous sommes là en bord de
mangrove là où se reproduisent poissons
et crustacés
c'est un empoisonnement dans un
environnement où tout le monde sait et
selon les études balance que les algues
sargasse contiennent des métaux lourds
de la sonic non organiques et du cadmium
il aurait dû chercher un endroit
approprié pour ce stockage provisoire
on ne jette pas du poison dans un
environnement protégé qui s'appelle la
mangrove le maire de sainte marie
confirme bien ce choix de stockage
provisoire
le ramassage des sargasses ayant eu lieu
ce week-end suivi de deux jours fériés
la campagne électorale a sept maris et
terminé au jeu nous sommes dans l'action
monsieur lucien est nous reproche de
faire des choses nous rapprochent de
nous j'occupe est vraiment de
l'enlèvement des sargasses sur la ville
de sète ma vie il a bien fallu à quelque
part stocker les sargasses à un audois
donc pour nous l'endroit le plus le
mieux adapté c'était justement sur le
site de la richesse en soi ça ne gêne
personne
une réunion préfecture justement
déterminée ou déverser ses stocks bien
encombrant ce matin une équipe du rsma
étaient à pied d'oeuvre justement la
riche et faute de bennes mises à
disposition pour l'évacuation
ils ont dû cesser le travail en fin de
matinée